Floyd Mayweather beats Conor McGregor in  10th round TKO oh where doesn't win no  matter how you get it announces he's  officially retiring this was my last  fight tonight ladies and gentleman my  last fight the 40 year old athlete  became the first boxer to reach 50  fights undefeated on Saturday night  during the much-anticipated showdown  with the 29 year old MMA fighter it all  went down at the t-mobile Arena in Las  Vegas Nevada Jennifer Lopez Alex  Rodriguez Charlize Theron and many more  stars were in attendance  Demi Lovato was a vision in white  opening the show with the national  anthem and during Mayweather's post  fight interview he said the match would  be his last I think we gave the fans  what they wanted wanted to see  [Music]  you